today's topic is is yet another video
that makes me realize that men are
disposable
it is wild i had a i had a full
instagram live that blew me away
ladies basically coming on and saying
that men are not necessary for the
future of humanity
i'm gonna play the video yes yes yes so
but apparently you feel
you feel some type of way it said i
think you said that you really want to
be
a mother on your own uh yeah uh it's not
really want to be
it's like it's it's gonna happen it's
happening so i'm 27
uh and i've wanted a kid since i was 23
but i've waited because um i was with a
partner he didn't want a child
and so afterwards i was like okay well
like this is not gonna work
um i'm gonna so i split up with him
um and i started looking for like
somebody else
couldn't find anybody else um tried
still looking
um and then i was like you know what
actually i could actually just do this
by myself why can't i do it by myself um
so
the thing is like i'm i'm getting ready
for this like uh
financially i'm putting myself in like a
good position
um buying what i believe i need to buy
i'm also doing my research
um and it's not like i'm just going to
jump into it
it's like i'm actively just preparing
myself to do this
um so yeah i was raised by a single
mother my father makes like way less
than my mom does my father my
mom my mom is like at a high position
she makes good money
uh my father um is a bus driver in
france he makes like
bare minimum wage yeah he has like
advanced advantages but like it doesn't
really
do much she doesn't even collect like
child
um yeah so so so basically because he
couldn't provide you think he would have
made the situation
not any better yeah basically
like it would just like i feel like he
would have been more of a weight
than a help yeah and you don't feel like
you missed out on anything with not
having a father
uh no no
if i look at like a stereotypical movie
then yeah i didn't play baseball or
whatever with my dad he was like
throwing me the ball and i was hitting
it like okay
could you could you imagine that another
person in your situation would have
liked to have a father yes okay
and so you couldn't imagine that your
child is going to go through that exact
same thing yes
which is why uh in um so i don't wanna
get just like a sperm donor like i'm
looking
for uh in my situation where i wanna be
a single mother i'm looking for somebody
who i know
or somebody who i will eventually meet
that will be okay
with providing me um well the sperm
but will stay in touch with the child if
the child
um wants to be in touch with them
okay and if that man who gives you the
sperm and stays in touch
if he has like another family and other
kids and
and prioritizes them over your child
what are you gonna do then
i mean um like it's his like i i'm gonna
be totally totally honest with the child
like how the situation is is um
that we are um an abnormal family and
that we don't we're not like a
conventional he is not
conventionally being brought up uh
probably gonna be teased about it at
school
um it's not gonna be easy et cetera and
and then i'm also gonna explain to him
um like the situation with his dad like
whether he can contact
him or not um and all of that
okay okay but you understand the child
didn't choose this life that you chose
it for him
it's not like you you're telling him
after the fact that he has to deal with
something that's not ideal and very
hurtful
and potential it's just that it's not
it's not the usual but i'm not like
you're saying it's not ideal you don't
know what it's going to be like for the
child
you're saying that from your perspective
as you as an individual you don't know
what the child is going to want
so so when you say that you're saying
that after the fact the child has been
brought into this world you brought him
right
nobody he didn't ask to be brought here
and then afterwards you'd like
by the way uh because of the way that i
wanted to bring you into this world
you're not going to have a father i mean
he gave you sperm and he brought you
here but he's got his own family now and
he probably
is more focused on them you understand
like he's already here he can't choose
to leave he can't go back up your womb
like
i don't like this offer i'm out i want
to bring the child as well because i
really want one
and it might not be a situation he likes
i recognize he might get bullied for it
and he might dislike it but i'mma tell
him i'm gonna have a conversation well
that doesn't matter if you have a
conversation with him
or her because you only told them after
you put them in that situation
that's like me bringing you to a party
okay and
everyone there is violent i locked the
door behind you and i'm like by the way
people in here are violent so you might
get punched
does that sound like it makes sense i
mean
no but um
i'm asking you a different question is
the child your priority
yes do you acknowledge the fact that for
most people
raised in single parent households the
outlook on life is not very positive in
terms like the numbers and all these
other issues do you recognize that
i haven't i haven't looked at the
numbers i just heard it in
your live stream and bro ask me
how this girl says she's been
researching and preparing to be a single
part
and she doesn't even know the numbers
she doesn't know the stats she hasn't
read
because she hasn't read the literature
nothing because she's gonna research on
what she's not gonna
she's gonna research on what i need to
do to raise a kid
uh i need to i need to dress them
i need to uh how much money does it take
and that's pretty much [ __ ] well not
concerned about the mental
office is not concerned about the
predicament well
concerned about that it's not the first
thing that comes to mind people whenever
they tell the story of themselves
they set them out to be the hero so she
sets out to be you know what i'm gonna
do a great job
it's all good i'm gonna do that i'm
gonna sit him down i'm gonna talk to him
and everything's gonna be fine
they're not looking at the fact that
it's a possibility that you're trying to
look at you and be like
so let me get this straight mom you just
decided
that my my life is gonna be hell knowing
that and you just put me there and
everything's gonna be fine
yeah well you're [ __ ] stupid because
a child can do that
a rebellious child can absolutely tell
you yo you're
[ __ ] idiot you're stupid maybe not
that language but they can't resent you
i can tell you right now there are so
many kids from single parent households
who resent their parent
because their parent pushed away their
father or their mother or
totally or always spoke terribly about
one of them
and so as a result they're like yo you
you pitted me against him
or her and they weren't nearly as bad
there's so many people like that
so you know and people but it's not
going to happen
but it's not going to happen to me
because i'm going to sit him down
and we're going to have a discussion if
this is the thing that kills me it's
like
listen transparency isn't a blanket
a forgiveness check just because you're
transparent with someone after the fact
it doesn't mean that you've done a good
thing you you can't slap someone be like
i did it because i was angry at you
afterwards and think it makes it okay
that's not the way it works yep i just
i don't know it blows me away because
this person's talking about i've done
all this research i've prepared i've
done all that i'm like great fantastic
good for you
do you know the numbers do you know the
stats do you know the studies have you
researched like
the literature on children from these
kind of households what is it like when
there's a sperm don't have you even
looked into
what their stories are like or what this
numbers say for kids in those
environments and how they're raised like
it just it frightens me
just how flippant people are with like
yeah the kid's not gonna need that dad
how could you and you know what's
interesting
she acknowledged she understood that
even though she says she claims she
didn't need a father and she was fine
without it which
you know maybe she was maybe she's one
of the few right
she says that right and then i asked her
if someone else was in your circumstance
could you imagine that they needed a dad
and she's like yeah i could imagine that
i'm like
so you can't imagine that your child
would be feeling the same
way
that never occurred to you no no but she
went
well i know it's just that and change
the subject they don't really
they never address it they never address
it no they never address it they don't
stop and listen to no did you listen to
what i just said to you no
did you did you listen or you really
what you actually really want
is more important they never address it
it's just like yeah okay i hear
i heard you yeah you heard you didn't
listen
um i do know other single parented
people and they're like they're fine
okay let's be careful let's be careful
i'm not talking about anecdotes
i got my experience that's wonderful you
got your experience that's wonderful
but we can't do any dodo right because i
can point to three families who did
great and i could point to 10 families
who did
terrible what does the father bring um
other than the finances like what
mentorship guidance a male perspective
it's completely different
it art it affects women actually far
more because women grow up to be far
more attached to their fathers and they
ever do their mothers
and that is a pattern that is constantly
repeated across
every society that's why they have the
term daddy's girl
right that's a very common thing so when
you say to me like what importance it's
like
this is like a new thing in society now
where we're like starting to
downplay the importance and the
influence of having a male
or a father figure in people's lives and
we're turning it obsolete and when you
sit there and you ask me like what
importance
that's frightening that you like don't
even have any idea of what
a child may be missing out on by not
having a father i understand that you
may think you're okay with it and that
you are fine and maybe you are i'm not
trying to tell you you're broken or
whatever
but a lot of other people out there are
yeah yeah
it's because you were cool with it
doesn't mean your child will be so
if you say you're ready and you're
preparing i doubt that
you provide enough because it doesn't
seem like you understand why a child
needs a father
and that frightens me that you think
you're ready to bring a child in this
world but you don't understand why a kid
may need a father do you not see how
crazy
you're ready i am preparing
right but that should be something but
you're saying you're to do this by
yourself that should be one of the first
things you learn about
all right if i'm going to make this
decision without a father what does that
mean to not know that a father is not
going to be there
the fact that you don't know that and
you say you're preparing like
has not one of the first steps that you
take before you get your finances in
order before you do anything else
i do not know that most people talk
about the finances so that like that's
what i've been focusing on um and
um like i'm getting there but that's i
mean this is this is interesting and i'm
definitely you know i'm gonna look into
it but
like please please do please do because
i can bring on a whole bunch of people
here who are from single-parent
households
and i'm telling you they'll tell you
like not having my dad or mom in my life
[ __ ] me up
i'm gonna scuba dive without the oxygen
tank
the first thing you should look at is
what are the effect of pressure without
a
oxygen tank or what is it gonna do to
your lungs
or what is it what is not having what
not
maybe i'm being too logical maybe i'm
really being too logical with this thing
but what are the effects of that if
you're going to climb the everest
without oxygen tanks
well you should look into what it means
not to have oxygen on top of the everest
what could happen what are the
statistics
bro to me it's not even just what
they're saying it's how
there's a comp there's like no awareness
there's like i'm asking these questions
it's like the first time that they've
heard it i'm like
how how do you not know that people need
their parents
you want to become a parent but you
haven't this is like
basics but they have zero idea
they have zero idea it's crazy how
flippant people are
about marriage and about
bringing children to this world it's so
frightening to me with all the research
and all the readily available
information that we have like
just how just how you know that's the
thing that kills me
but i'm gonna just play the end of this
clip and that's okay well listen when it
comes to adoption i think i make a
little bit of a concession there because
there's a kid out there who has nobody
so one parent is better than nobody
all right i think i can make that
argument what i would say and i think
where the
conversation needs to be steered toward
there's also acknowledging the fact that
most of the time when people don't have
partners around the age of 35 or
whatever it is
yeah generally it's not just there
wasn't any luck a lot of it also comes
down to
well what is that you're looking for
what kind of concessions are you willing
to make are you willing to compromise on
things that you think are absolutely
important
rather be alone then compromise on a lot
of these important things
then you also have to acknowledge that
there's a bit of a choice that goes into
the fact that you're alone
and you're raising this child by
yourself uh you're essentially and i'm
not saying it's your situation because i
don't know you what i'm saying is
people are essentially saying i don't
want to compromise on my standards so
i'd rather be
alone but i'm also going to raise a
child an environment where
i'm going to prioritize my own standards
over what they're going to need
potentially for them
and i think that's the attitude that i
have an issue with yeah you know we had
this conversation you and i before
and i was basically telling you it's
just people don't know the importance of
men and i think they
sometimes perfectly try to pretend like
men aren't
important you know we get blamed for all
these mistakes and at the same time
we're told we're not necessary so it's
not surprising to me that men are
checking out of dating
at insanely high rates you know you know
what like i'm starting to turn the
corner i thought you know people are way
more balanced and nuanced than this but
i'm starting to turn the corn i'm like
yo you know what i'm starting to
understand why these dudes is just like
yo
these ladies is bugging because the way
that they're talking about raising kids
by themselves and all this other stuff
i'm like
since when listen i was raised by a
single mom god bless her she did she did
the best job that she could
she still didn't do a good job she still
didn't do a good job
and that's not her fault entirely
because of the circumstances around her
you know she did
the best that she could but it doesn't
mean that her best that she could was a
great environment to be raised in
the stress that it put on her how much
it negatively
impacted her the choices and the
sacrifices that she had to make long
term in her life
it wasn't easy go talk to almost any
single mom out there they're gonna tell
you it's
one of the most difficult lives but then
what kind of messaging are we telling
these young women where it's like yeah
you should voluntarily choose this if
you can
that's crazy the trauma that they're
going to put on themselves
and on the children that they raise zero
consideration
i did not hear a single woman who came
on that live that day
who said they were for this and who even
understood that concept
it frightened the [ __ ] out of me bro if
you're for this
thing that is a sign of being unaware if
you're aware of everything that it
everything that it takes and you still
want to do it
then you're maybe in a higher privilege
like money wise or whatever you're good
good but even then i mean it's still
messed up
it's not great it's not fun just to be
there and there's something that you
i hope you're surrounded by people that
can fulfill that place but
it's not everybody that i can you want
to raise a child by yourself and
it's it's not a it's not a great thing
and it's just it's really it is really a
um
it's really shows that men are
disposable
man and society are very disposable very
yeah it shows that men are disposable
and that a lot of these women are
irresponsible
yeah you know and i would say the same
thing to the dudes who get these women
pregnant and then leave like
they're also extremely irresponsible
definitely but there's more at risk for
the ladies
because they get they get saddled with
the child at the end of the day
yeah it's like if there's more at risk
for you got to understand what that
means to to raise that kid by
on yourself potentially you know and to
be very careful with that and
and to really think that over before you
get into that situation
i'm gonna be a homeless it's not camping
it's very difficult but i don't pay rent
it's more than that and it's a bit the
same thing it's more than not just
paying rent
you understand like it's it's more than
that and the people
that are in that predicament it's not
it's not a choice a lot of them is not a
choice a lot of them is
but it's still not most of them it's not
a choice things happen and stuff like
that
they wouldn't want to be in that spot
yeah so you saying that's what i'm gonna
do
i don't know it's super weird to me you
know what i'm gonna say i'm gonna say
this a child is not an accessory it's
not something that you want because it
looks cool and it looks cute
this is your legacy this is the thing
that you pass down this is something
that you're planting in society and
setting it out there to have an
influence and a ripple effect
it's not for you to carry like a birkin
bag that's not what that is so if you're
going to bring this baby into this world
this child this thing that you're going
to mold
you have the responsibility to give
yourself
the best tools to mold that child
even if it means you dip into your
savings even if it means that you're
going to be unhappy
you have maybe what i'm saying is
controversial i don't think it is
i don't even care if it makes you
unhappy i don't care i personally don't
care
because at the end of the day if you're
voluntarily choosing to bring a life we
didn't ask to be here
preach would you agree with me that
every child should be a parent's
priority
yeah that's the point okay this would
what do you want me to say
and everyone's like well you know what i
but i just i was out of luck and i
couldn't fight
no because you know what i bet you 155
if i went through your dm's there's a
bunch of guys who were interested in you
that you weren't interested
either because they were attractive
enough unambitious enough didn't make
enough money whatever it might be
you didn't have any chemistry with them
i don't care if you don't have chemistry
if you're going to say i'm going to
voluntarily choose to bring a life in
this world [ __ ] you better settle
and same goes to the men if if men were
talking crazy like this i would say the
same thing
the audacity of people to say i want to
raise a child by myself
but i wouldn't settle but you make that
child settle for something that's not
right for them
it's crazy to me it's crazy like
parents who will move to neighborhoods
where their children are going to be
extremely unhappy
just because the parents didn't want to
be unhappy where they were living
selfish as well your child's happiness
and their well-being and their mental
health is the most important thing
but you don't want to settle it's crazy
this generation of parents blows my
mind i would even argue that our parents
generation were also terrible like that
too
how flippant they were with divorces and
the mental effect that it had on the
next generation afterwards
insane but did they care
no because now we've become such an
individualistic society that the
individual is more important than the
collective the family unit
that's pretty much it i i just don't get
it i just don't get it sorry it's not i
don't get it i'm just like the audacity
that's what i think
yeah it's really what i said before they
they don't want the role
they want the possession [ __ ]
want a car
payment don't want they want a car no
car payment and they don't want to put
no gas in it
you know there's wanting a car and being
a driver
you're a driver of your car you have to
pay insurance you have to pay for your
license plate you have to pay for your
gas you have to pay for all of that
for the repairs it's not just having a
car there's people that just want a car
and then they skip payments to skip this
and skip that they're not really
responsible with this
because what they wanted was the car i
want to floss i want to shine
i want to put some mags on it when the
car payment comes around
when the instruments payment come around
when the did they skip on it
there's that maturity they see that you
know what i mean
i'd rather go pop bottles with my
friends and i'm oh [ __ ] i don't have
money with that
maybe you took a bar a car that was too
big for you the problem is that
a car is just a car it's just a
possession now they do the same way that
they deal with things that they did with
kids
how they didn't do that i want to have a
baby yes
but when the baby wants to wake up you
have to go there when the baby asks too
many questions you have to answer them
when the baby this one the baby that
you're there because you don't have a
baby when you have a baby
you're a parent and there's a difference
and that is the difference
and people do not make the difference
between having a baby and
being a parent but there is there's a
huge difference it's like being a father
and being a dad
are you going to be a dad to that kid or
you're going to be a father
you're going to be there preach all
right listen i think that's the perfect
note to end it on
yeah tell us what you guys think in the
comments below like what do you guys
think about the stuff that you're
hearing
and do you think this is good or bad and
i don't say it's to put any of these
women on blasts
but i think it's going to be good for
them to watch this back and to realize
what they sound like before they make
the big decision of bringing a child
into this world
because i think everyone should
understand what that means because then
maybe we wouldn't have so many kids from
divorced parents
or single parent households in certain
situations i'm not saying it's this idea
of like wanting to have a child by
yourself that's causing it
it's more so this selfishness and this
irresponsibility that's causing a lot of
these divorces where people prioritize
themselves
over the well-being of the children yes
i said it there's a lot of people who
should have stayed in marriages to make
sure that their kids were okay
hot take yeah you don't get to have that
chemistry in that spark that you had
with your husband
or your wife sorry sorry you don't wanna
know why because your kids mental well
and well-being
is more important at least wait till
they go off to college or university
before you do that
how many kids do i know who were
traumatized because you guys divorced
when you were
and caused a huge ripple effect in
fighting like it's just
i don't know it's just this selfishness
that's like pervasive and it throws me
off so
maybe you guys feel differently maybe my
hot take is too hot
but uh you know for me the idea of till
death do
do his part there's there's an
importance to that
there's an importance to that and i
think we've lost that so i think until
this to us apart is more important when
you have a kid than when you're married
but that's just me that's just me
hey so that's what the part ain't about
it ain't about the marriage but when you
have a kid
it should be that but okay listen on
that note
let us know what you guys think in the
comments
[Music]
foreign